[Music]
in terms of starch wars the thing that
was really disrupted the most
was solo
because it had i can't remember the two
guys that were originally um
directing it
but you know the actors went to the
producer and complained this is i don't
even know what the [ __ ] this is
you know she and i guess is kathleen
kennedy that the one yeah that they
ratted it out to
and you know
how many times have we seen that in the
last few years when i mean look what
they did to
the schneider with um you know justice
league oh justice league
that would never have happened under
marvel because kevin feige would never
have let it happen you know you've like
said you've got the captain of the ship
you've got somebody steering him in the
right direction
um
that's one of the things i worry now
that it's disney they've got star wars
and i think it is spencer's got it down
right this it's it's by committee and
they keep
everything's i think good ideas go in
one end and they just get the crap
kicked out of them and they summit comes
out the other end but then you get but
it's why mandalorian worked because
you've got favreau
who obviously loves the the genre he
loves the the project
and is the captain the ship he wrote
several of the episodes he directed a
few and but even when he hasn't he's
still that executive producer in charge
making sure it's going in the right
direction and even though i actually
didn't like mandalorian when it first
came out
i thought it was boring
um i then just
adored it he's back
um my internet went down
we got to talk for a minute it was great
it was wonderful
[Laughter]
sorry
um
dc
all over the bloody place
and marvel they've got kevin feige keeps
it all in the right direction
the solo movie
was oh god yeah where they they
fired everybody involved and then
and changed them halfway through yeah
and you can tell in the film i i to be
honest i think they got that film wrong
from the start the casting's wrong
they shouldn't i think they shouldn't
have even thought about making a film i
hate prequels they shouldn't they
shouldn't have bothered
is it is it bad jay that i actually
quite enjoyed so though
yeah we have opposite opinions and
you're wrong about a lot of things
i like
but i also write about a lot of things
you know the you know the um
i like the origin story bit you know
between uh
and chewie that was kind of fun
other glimpses of
the empire especially getting the [ __ ]
kicked out of them in just the worst
parts of the galaxy so we always see the
shining ships and the death stars but
this was like you know
it looks like you know at least the
scenes were where they met it was like
oh here's the empire's version of
vietnam yeah yeah yeah yeah
i hadn't seen that before and that was
it was it was good it was good
i i found it for everything that the
film went through the story and the
production because remember ron howard
was stuck with a a steaming pile of [ __ ]
i mean he a lot of the original uh
uh scenes he just had to oh he looked at
all the reels and
well that's her shave footage
well footage is even wrong in the
digital age he saw what he had and he
knew what he'd have to do to correct
some of the things along and then he
just started reshoot
some reshooting and then a lot of
additive stuff
and with with the the absolute
[ __ ] that the production was i
think ron howard did an admiral job to
bring out a
yeah damn right
let's not pretend it's not rogue one
it's not wrong you know don't shoot me
in the comments but i thought it was it
was a it was a good effort on his part
and he really did save the movie i mean
it was powerful
actually
you should say that
it's funny
but it was still bad
it wasn't bad it was boring i don't
think it was i thought it was really
good i enjoyed sailing i know it's i
tell you what no it's genuinely
forgettable as we're talking about i'm
going oh yeah everybody um
i'm trying to remember the film and it's
like i mean you you you know you had the
sexual tension between vision and uh
daenerys stormborn you know
it was just
yeah but no no no storm storm you've
just you've literally proved a point
there where the only reason that you
care about those characters because
they've been other characters
she's been in two big franchises and
she's ruined both of them she was
terrible
she was terrible in solo but well no she
did she didn't ruin game of thrones
as soon as she stopped getting her boobs
out because she got too powerful i was
not interested
[Music]